we're asked to simplify 9p to the 2/3
all of that over the square root of 4 P
cubed so let's just do this step by step
the first thing we can do is say well if
it's nine pieces of two-thirds that's
the same thing as 9 to the 2 9 to the
2/3 times P to the 2/3 that's what this
top part can be simplified to now the
bottom part we can rewrite the bottom
part right here the square root of 4 P
to the third this is the exact same
thing as 4 P to the third to the
one-half power this is the same thing
the square root of 4 P to the third is
the same thing as 4 P to the third to
the one-half power so given that we can
do the same thing that we did on the
numerator we can say well this is the
same thing as 4 to the 1/2 4 to the 1/2
times P to the third to the one-half
power now let's see if we can simplify
this even more so this is going to be
equal to let's do the denominator first
here so it's 4 to the 1/2 power what's
the principal root of 4 well 2 squared
is 4 so it's to the positive root is 2
and then P to the third and then that to
the 1/2 that's the same thing as P to
the 3 times 1/2 or P to the three-halves
P to the 3 over 2 9 to the 2/3 see the
cube root of 9 is into anything easy
well actually we could think about this
way you could say it's 9 squared so it
can view 9 to the 2/3 let me do it this
way this is the best way to think about
it this 9 to the 2/3 one could write it
I'm kind of making it unsimplified it
but it'll help us calculate it what it
actually means 9 to the 2/3 is the same
thing as 9 squared 9 squared to the 1/3
power right because 2 times 1/3 is 2/3
and then you have that of course times P
to the 2/3 and this is going to be equal
to 9 squared is 81 so it's 81 to the 1/3
power times P
the 2/3 times P to the 2/3 now instead
of writing this to and this P to the
three-halves down here let me just write
it as negative exponents or even let's
write just write it like this
a 2 in the denominator is the same thing
as 2 to the negative 1 or 1/2 so this
right here if I want to write in the
numerator same thing as 1/2 that and
that are the same thing and P to the
three-halves in the denominator is the
same thing as P as P to the negative P
to the negative three-halves so this
whole expression so far has been
simplified to this right over here and
let me copy and paste it I'll work on
the next line now so let me copy it and
paste bring it down right over there
let's see if we can simplify this even
more so let's think about 81 let's see
if we can write it as we're essentially
when we take something to the cube when
we take the cube root of something we're
taking some when we take something to
the 1/3 power taking the cube root of it
so we have to find some numbers or maybe
we can factor it into things that do
have cube roots and other things that
don't so 81 is what's divisible by 3
it's 3 times 27 which is 3 times 9 which
is 3 times 3 so 81 is 3 to the fourth
power or it's 3 multiplied by itself 3
times so we could rewrite this 81 to the
1/3 we could rewrite it as 3 times 3
times 3 to the well I'll write it like
this times 3 to the 1/3 that's the same
thing as 81 and then let's think about
this these peas and I'm doing more steps
than I would do if I had to do it on a
piece of paper because I really want you
all to understand kind of what's going
on here so we have a P to the 2/3 times
P to the negative 3 halves so that's
going to be times P to the 2/3 2/3 minus
3 halves power and then so we did the
peas and then we just have the times 1/2
times 1/2 now this right over here this
is the same thing this is the same thing
we could just view this as three times
three times three times three so it's
the same thing as 3 times 3 times 3 to
the 1/3 times 3 to the 1/3 right we've
done this multiple times times the two
two-thirds minus three halves let's just
work that out actually three halves is
the larger number so let's just say it's
the negative of three halves minus
two-thirds which is equal to the
negative if we use 6 as a common
denominator if we use 6 as a common
denominator 3 halves with six of the
denominators nine six minus four over
six that's what two-thirds is equal to
so 9 minus 4 is 5 6 and then we have
this negative out here so that equals
negative 5/6 so times P to the negative
5/6 power times one half times that last
1/2 over here now 3 times 3 times 3 or
27 to the 1/3 the cube root of 27 is 3
so this right here simplifies to 3 and
then 3 to the 1/3 that's the cube root
of 3 so because they have 3 and then
this right here is the cube root of 3
the cube root of 3 so we get 3 times the
cube root of 3 times P to the negative
5/6
so sometimes you might want to write the
P out here in front of the radical that
tends to be a simpler way actually let
me do that so I'll write the P to the
negative 5/6 P to the negative 5/6 then
I'll write the radical so times the cube
root of 3 and then all of that times 1/2
or we could say all of that multiplying
times 1/2 or you could just divide it by
2 and we've simplified it about as far
as you can go you could view it as 3
halves you could say 3 halves is 1.5 P
to the negative 5/6 times the cube root
of 3 if you wanted to you could
calculate the cube root of 3 multiply
that times 1/2 give you some decimal
number times P to the negative 5/6 and
that's about as simplified as this thing
can get